here in New York a marine veteran has
turned himself in for the killing of a
man on the subway in front of multiple
Witnesses Jordan Neely died after Daniel
Penny put him in a Chokehold after
Witnesses said he behaved erratically
penny is expected to face second-degree
manslaughter charges at his arraignment
Lilia Luciano was at the courthouse
Lilia good morning
good morning to you Dana this case has
been a flash point here in New York City
bringing up issues and conversations
around homelessness around mental
illness and what resources are or aren't
available for people ever since that
video that was taken by a bystander of
Jordan Neely's death became public a
warning to our viewers these images are
disturbing
after 10 days of protests across New
York Manhattan prosecutors are charging
Daniel penny for Jordan Neely's death
officials and friends say Neely
struggled with homelessness and mental
illness for years and he worked as a
Michael Jackson impersonator on May 1st
Witnesses say he was on the subway
acting erratically and screaming about
being hungry and tired that's when video
captured Penny held by two other
passengers tackling Neely and putting
him in a choke hold
Penny was questioned by police and
released the medical examiner determined
Neely's death was a homicide caused by
compression of the neck certainly a
reasonable jury would not believe that
Daniel Penny intended to kill Jordan
melee but a jury could believe Beyond a
reasonable doubt that the actions were
not justified and that they were
Reckless lawyers for Penny said in a
statement that he stepped in to protect
himself and his fellow New Yorkers when
we spoke to the Neely family attorney
before the arrest he said they wanted
Penny to be held accountable Jordan's
story could be anybody else anybody
else's family member anybody else's
loved one organizers in lower Manhattan
called the arrest a small victory
there's a long road and a long War to be
fought but today we won a battle for the
people and for the family of Jordan
Neely
according to authorities Neely had more
than 40 arrests he also had more than a
dozen mental health encounters with
police we asked a former Manhattan
assistant D.A about this he said these
charges will likely not factor into the
case unless Penny could somehow prove
that he knew about them before the
encounter and no one else so far has
been charged in this case Gail
all right Lilia thank you just a
horrible story sad all the way around